I'm taking a break from decorating for my daughter's birthday because,
A, I think I'm gonna collapse,
and B, because I just left around my mouth.
So let's go. The white women on this app who are like,
how do I make you feel safe around me?
Black women. How do I, um,
do better? It's giving
like the husband who asks for a list, right?
Like, I'm here to help.
Just tell me how to help.
Not realizing that you were causing more work and labor on their part.
The information is out there,
and I know that because it's on TikTok.
There are black women on here who have tirelessly been educating
into the ethos for years now.
So if you actually wanted the information,
you could find it. You just want it, like,
spoon fed to you
because you don't want to do any fucking work or effort at all,
and you want a participation trophy in self education. Also,
I think part of it is kind of, like, nefarious.
And this might be just, like,
being kind of a hater,
but I think it's so you can have black women come in your comments
and they be angry at you. So you could be like,
I asked, I did the work.
And they were so mean. They were so defensive,
when in reality, this is the equivalent of, like,
Susie and Johnny. Susie has four kids.
She's overwhelmed. She's running the house.
She's got the chores. And the lists and schedules,
and Johnny just walks in with his, like,
dirty shoes, and it's like, yeah, yeah,
I'm here to help. That is like,
performative acting. You want,
like, the participation.
You're not actually helping.
And listen, nobody knows what they don't know.
But maybe try switching up that algorithm.
Maybe get some different things coming to your feed.
And don't get me wrong, I am not better than anyone, okay?
Like, white supremacy is the default of our society.
You have to unlearn that shit.
And it takes work, and it takes effort,
and it takes intention, and it takes listening,
and it is an ongoing process.
So I don't blame anyone
for being at a lower chapter
of their journey of education and deconstruction than I am.
But I am saying, like,
I didn't ask for help, like,
out loud. The information's out there.
Cause you'd give shit to Chad for asking for a list, too.